coffee on a Tuesday in blog 26 I'm back
baby in the spring of 1818 the poet John
Keats wrote a letter to his friend John
Hamilton Reynolds which contained in it
a poetic metaphor for how he saw human
life he called it the mansion of many
apartments and the image goes sort of
like this the first apartment we step
into he calls the thoughtless chamber
here we remain for as long as we do not
think now I think Keats means by this
thinking deeply philosophically
poetically etc and the whole time were
in this chamber this apartment the door
to the next apartment is wide open
showing a bright appearance on the other
side now at first maybe we have no
motivation to move toward it but slowly
eventually the thinking principal impels
us too and we go in now once we get
inside into the second chamber which
Keats calls the chamber of made and
thought we become intoxicated by the
light and atmosphere we see nothing but
pleasant wonders and think of delaying
there forever and delight in other words
we get a taste of the ideal then the
mood changes one of the effects of
sharpening one's mind in the chamber of
Maidan thought is that one begins to see
deeper into the heart of man into the
misery pain sickness and oppression that
the world is full of these things
gradually begin to darken the chamber
fill it with the fog but at the same
time that it gets dark on all sides of
the room doors are set open leading away
to dark passages which it then becomes
ones choice to take or not take you can
see that even in a letter Keats's powers
of description are extraordinary he
later coined the term negative
capability a concept to describe an
artist who understanding the inherit
mysteries of life could find the
strength to remain to be in
uncertainties mysteries doubts without
any irritable
reaching after fact and reason he cited
Shakespeare as a key example of an
artist who had achieved this in 1890 a
year after the letter to John Reynolds
Keats writes his ode to a nightingale
one of his best works indeed one of the
best works of poetry in my opinion eight
stands as long the poem tells of the
narrator's reaction to hearing the song
of a nightingale the bird being
representative of the ideal and his
profound longing to join it even at the
expense of his life the poem starts with
the narrator becoming paralyzed by the
bird song which commences a journey
through the layers of his soul now in a
minute I'm just going to put a link up
here probably right here to another
video where I'll recite the poem for you
because poems like this should be heard
and in the corner somewhere in one of
these corners I'm going to put numbers
corresponding to the stanza so that
you'll have a signpost as as we go along
try to keep in mind the metaphor of the
mansion of many apartments and the
concept of negative capability while I'm
reading it also it might be worthwhile
to say that the general rule with art is
that you can have any feeling about it
that you damn well please
but whatever you like whatever you know
you fancy in terms of art it's good to
memorize poems I highly recommend it and
if you want to memorize one of your
favorite poems and and recite it and
post it as a rated video response
I will most certainly put it up on the
video so the link should be there now
maybe here I don't know click click on
it Oh to a nightingale by John Keats
click here right here to hear my face is
now the link it's a good poem I promise
you have to believe me you have to
believe me please believe me please
believe me have you clicked yet